الجاسوس الذي لم يجلس في المقاهي لينقل الأخبار،
ولم يذهب للمنشآت العسكرية والاقتصادية،
هو لم يخرج إلى الشارع أيضا ليباشر عمله،
عمل مع الموساد الإسرائيلي وخان وطنه
ليحصل على المال،
باع بلاده ليحصل على الدكتوراة
وهو في الأساس لم يكمل الإعدادية،
دخل كطبيب في قصر أحد أقوى الرؤساء العرب
واستمر بأعماله التجسسية لعدة سنوات،
لكن ،،،،كيف غفلت عنه  أحد أقوى المخابرات في العالم؟
أم أنهم كانوا يعرفونه ولكن قرروا استخدامه
دون أن يعرف؟
وهل كان لهذا الجاسوس دورا في موت الرئيس جمال عبدالناصر
الجاسوس الذي دخل قصر الرئاسة المصرية،
للقصة بقية
ولد علي خليل العطفي في حي السيدة زينب بالقاهرة
عام ١٩٢٢،
لكن أعلى ما استطاع الحصول عليه هي الشهادة الإعدادية،
عندها ذهب ليعمل كصبي في بقالة،
وانتقل ليعمل في أحد الأفران، ثم ذهب ليعمل في صيدلية،
إلى أن انتهى به المطاف بالعمل في مهنة التدليك،
وهي مهنة نادرة في ذلك الوقت ولا يهتم بها الا الطبقة الراقية في المجتمع،
تقول إحدى الروايات أن علي العطفي كان هو المدلك الخاص
بالرئيس جمال عبدالناصر،
وفي يوم مز الأيام أعطاه الموساد الإسرائيلي مرهما
ليستخدمه في تدليك الرئيس لكن هذا المرهم كان مسموما،
وتسبب في مقتل الرئيس لكن تدريجيا وبطريقة بطيئة،
غير أن لا توجد أدلة على هذه الرواية وليست سوى أكذوبة
يحاول نشرها الموساد،،،
وبالعودة لقصتنا فقد كان علي العطفي يعمل مع طبيب تدليك
كمساعد ولم يكن هو المدلك الرئيسي،
وفي عام ١٩٦٣
يجد العطفي اسمه مدرجا ضمن الأسماء التي وافقت عليها الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
للسفر إليها، بعد ذلك ذهب العطفي إلى هولندا
وعاش فيها فترة من الزمن،
وخلال حياته في هولندا تزوج العطفي بشابة هولندية،
وكان لزوجته علاقات بالموساد الإسرائيلي في امستردام،
فذهب العطفي ذات يوم وعرض عليهم خدماته،
لكن ماذا سيستفيد الموساد من رجل لم يتعدى الإعدادية،
أخبرهم بكل تفاصيل حياته وأقنعهم أنه إذا حصل على شهادة الدكتوراة
فسيحقق لهم كل ما يريدون ويعمل لصالحهم لكن بالمقابل المادي الذي يطلبه،
وبعد تحققهم منه أعطوه الشهادة التي طلبها،
وتلقى العطفي تدريبا مكثفا على كيفية عمل المخابرات الإسرائيلية
واستخدام نظام تشفير الرسائل واستخدام الحبر السري
وجميع أساليب المخابرات، كما تم تدريب العطفي
في أرقى المستشفيات في هولندا على أيدي أمهر أطباء التدليك،
وبذلك صار خبيرا في التدليك دائم السفر خصوصا وأن زوجته
تعيش في هولندا وبذلك لن يسأله أحد عن سبب سفره الدائم،
كان العطفي يعمل كطبيب تدليك منذ ذلك الحين وظل على هذا العمل
وبدأت شهرت في مصر، حتى تم افتتاح أول معهد للعلاج الطبيعي
في مصر فاختاروا الغطفي ليكون أول عميد في المعهد،
وذات يوم وبينما هو في مكتبه جاءه طلب من مكتب رئاسة الجمهورية،
وفي المقابل تم إخباره إنه سيصبح أحد أطباء الرئيس أنور السادات،
وخصصت له سيارة تأخذه كل يوم من بيته في حي الزمالك،
وامتد عمل العطفي لجميع أفراد أسرة الرئيس ومقربيه،
ثم صارت عائلة صديقة لعائلة الرئيس وصار له نفوذ في الذهاب والعودة دون تفتيش،
وخلال ذلك كان العطفي يوصل جميع الأخبار والمعلومات للموساد،
وكان يبلغ الموساد بجميع تحركات الرئيس أولا بأول،
وظل في هذا العمل لسبع سنوات،
وفي إحدى زياراته لأمستردام، كانت المخابرات المصرية قد كشفته فعلا،
وكان له ملف باسم الجاسوس المجهول المقرب جدا
من دائرة القرار في مصر،
ولم يكن يعلم بأمره سوى ضباط محدودون
ولا يعلم أكثرهم به، عندها أرسلت المخابرات المصرية
أحد أفرادها ليعود مع العطفي في نفس الطائرة،
ولكن عند ركوبه الطائرة فوجئ بعدم وجود العطفي فيها،
وعاد للوطن، وعندما عاد ليبلغ بما حصل، كان محمد نسيم الشهير
ب (نسيم قلب الأسد)
هو من يتولى الأمر، وعندما أبلغه بالمعلومة قال له نسيم
أن كان في منزل العطفي كلب شرس للحراسة،
وأرادت المخابرات المصرية أن لا تلفت الانتباه وتقبض عليه بهدوء،
فاتصل به فرد من المخابرات وقال له أنه صحفي في صحيفة مشهورة آنذاك
ويريد إجراء لقاء صحفي معه لكنه يريد منه أن يبعد كلبه عن الحوش
لأنه يخاف الكلاب، فأدخل العطفي كلبه في إحدى الغرف،
وقبل الموعد بنصف ساعة توقفت أمام منزله سيارتين سوداوتين
لكنه كان أمر طبيعي لأنه يعمل في الرئاسة،
فتحت إحدى الشغالات باب العطفي فسألها الضابط
(هو فين الدكتور ، قالت هو جوا اتفضلوا ف صالة الانتظار)
لكن الضابط لم يسمعه واتجه لمكتب العطفي فورا ودخل عليه،
وقال (انته مأبوض عليك بتهمة التخابر مع الموساد الإسرائيلي،
رد العطفي، انته تعرف أنا مين، أن حأتصل بمكتب رئيس الجمهورية حالا،
رد الضابط احنا المخابرات المصرية ي فندم، وعند سماع الضجيج،
جاء ابن العطفي وشاهد تهديد الضباط لوالده، وأخبر والده بالألمانية،
أنا حا أكلم ابن ريس الجمهورية صاحبي،
فهم أحد الأفراد الموجودين وأخبر الضابط بمضمون حديث الولد،
فرد الضابط انته لو تكلم حتى الريس بذاته احنا هنأبض على أبوك،
عندها خارت قوى العطفي وجلس على كرسيه وقال،
أنا ندمت خلاص وقررت أتوب ورحت للموساد لامستردام من أسبوع أبلغهم الخبر،
أني خلاص ندمت ومش هاشتغل معهم تاني، وكنت كمان أسبوع
ها أروح لبيت الله الحرام واعمل عمرة، وه أشتغل معاكم
وأؤلكم اللي انتو عايزين بس ما تلمسونيش،
كان الضابط ذكيا وقال خلاص واحنا موافئين بس عشان تشتغل معانا
لازم نعرف ازي كنت تشتغل معاهم وإيه طلبو منك وازي كنت توصل لهم المعلومات،
فأخبرهم الحبر السري والشفرات وكل الأدوات والطرق التي يستخدمها مع الموساد)،
وتم إلقاء القبض عليه واعترف بكل شيء
وحكم عليه بالإعدام وتم رفض أي مبادلات مع إسرائيل
لكن الرئيس السادات قرر تخفيف الحكم وحكم عليه بالسجن ل١٥ عاما
مع الأشغال الشاقة، وحتى مع موت السادات
وتولي مبارك للحكم لم يستطع العطفي الخروج من السجن
ومات عام ١٩٩٠ في سجنه ورفضت عائلته استلام جثته
لأنه خائن لوطنه، وتم فبره في مقابر المجهولين،،،
فهل خدع العطفي المخابرات المصرية أم أنها هي كانت تخدعه؟
أم الاثنين خدعوا بعضهما إلى أن انتصرت المخابرت المصرية عليه؟...